MOVE TOWARDS 2020.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
THIS IS ANOTHER FOX NEWS ALERT,
MOMENTS AGO ALABAMA
GOVERNOR SIGNED ONE OF THE
STRICTEST ABORTION BILLS AND THE
COUNTRY INTO LAW.
REPORTS ON THE FIRESTORM IGNITED
ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS DEBATE,
ONE THAT COULD VERY WELL LEAD
ALL THE WAY TO THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
>> THE REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED
STATE SENATE VOTED 25 AND SIX TO
MAKE IT A FELONY FOR DOCTORS TO
PERFORM ABORTIONS IN ALABAMA AND
GLOSSY MOTHER'S LIFE IS
ENDANGERED.
THE MEASURE MAKES NO EXCEPTIONS
FOR CASES INVOLVING RAPE.
>> WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PROTECT LIFE.
>> OUTRAGE SOON FOLLOWED.
>> I APOLOGIZE TO THE WOMAN OF
ALABAMA FOR THIS LAW.
>> WE NEED TO LIFT UP THEIR
VOICES, THE VOICES OF WOMEN
ACROSS AMERICA WHO SEE THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM.
>> KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND PLANS TO
SPEAK TO MARK A WOMAN'S RALLY IN
GEORGIA, BRIAN KEMP SIGNED A
SIMILAR BILL LAST WEEK.
THE GEORGIA LAW HAS SPARKED
BOYCOTT BY THE FILM INDUSTRY
THAT SUPPORTS 1 MILLION JOBS.
MELISSA MILANO CALLED FOR A
NATIONAL STRIKE TWEETING, "UNTIL
WOMEN HAVE LEGAL CONTROL OVER
THEIR OWN BODIES WE CANNOT RISK
PREGNANCY.
JOIN ME IN NOT HAVING SEX UNTIL
WE GET AUTONOMY BACK."
>> LAST WEEK THE GLOVES WERE OFF
IN A SHOUTING MATCH DELAYED A
VOTE.
THE LEGISLATION WILL LIKELY FACE
AN IMMEDIATE LEGAL CHALLENGE.
>> THAT IS WHY WE WERE TRYING TO
KEEP IT.